In the wild, animals affect each others behavior
all the time—prey species keep away from
predators’ turf, insects jump away from
browsing herbivores—they may not be communicating
per se but they shape each others’ environment.
To further explore this relationship,
researchers used robots
to mediate between two species
unlikely to ever encounter each other in the wild:
zebrafish and honey bees.
The researchers chose these species because
they are both social and gregarious animals
who regularly make decisions as a group.
To do these experiments the animals were kept apart--
in fact, they are in different countries.
In Switzerland, a small school of zebrafish
swim around a circular path,
with a camera overhead tracking their position.
Swimming along with them is a robot lure,
the same size and shape as a zebrafish.
Meanwhile in Austria, a swarm of young bees
buzz around an oblong enclosure, with two
robots in the middle.
The bee-bots generate heat, which causes the bees
to congregate around them.
A proximity detector tracks the bees’ location.
In each setup, the fish and bees have a binary
collective choice to make - the bees can choose
to congregate around one of two robots
and the fish can swim either clockwise or
counterclockwise around the circle.
The researchers wanted to know if,
using robots as mediators,
the two species could come to
a collective decision -
could the species agree which direction to swim in and
which bee-robot to gather around?
Four different experiments were performed
with varying degrees of communication
between the animal groups.
The first experiment established a control group, with
no communication between the fish and the bees.
In the second experiment, the bees’ behavior
was observed and then transmitted to the fish robot,
affecting which way it lured the school of zebrafish.
After six minutes, the bees began to congregate
around the left bee robot, causing the fish robot
and, as a result, the fish
to swim in a counter clockwise direction.
In the third experiment, the fish’ behavior was observed
and then transmitted to the bee robots,
affecting which robot produced heat.
The fish constantly changed the direction
in which they were swimming, which caused
the bees to continuously switch sides as well.
In the final experiment, the behavior of both
the bees and the fish was observed,
and transmitted both ways
At first, the fish and bees couldn’t come to a decision--
one side did one thing, the
other another, with lots of switching back and forth.
But after about 20 minutes, they reached a consensus,
with the fish swimming counter-clockwise
and the bees congregating around the left bee-robot.
This shows that two species, which would have no
interaction whatsoever in nature,
are actually able to interact and come to a collective
decision thanks to the help of the robots.
Moving forward, researchers would like to introduce
machine learning into these types of scenarios
So bee-bots learn behavior from bees
and fish-bots from fish,
instead of being programmed ahead of time.
Researchers believe that in the future,
this technology could be used to mediate species
interactions not just in the laboratory,
but also in the wild—the research could even be
adapted to work with plants, fungi and microorganisms
One day, machine-learning robots could be used
to perceive a dramatic event in a bee colony,
and react to help the bees to find a way to recover.
This could be applied to any type of animal group, once
the robot knows how they make collective decisions.